bonsoir et bienvenue dans votre moment
de télévision préférée sur terre c'est
vrai on peut le dire
décollage d'Artémis 1
nous nous élançons ensemble
vers la lune et au-delà
devant le spectacle le commentateur de
la NASA est en extase le troisième
lancement a été le bon Artémis la plus
puissante fusée construite par l'homme
file vers la lune tel un soleil qui
éclaire la nuit la troisième tentative
prendra donc été la bonne au bout d'une
nuit de suspense en Floride vous voyez
cette image cette image qui va rentrer
dans l'histoire dans un bruit
assourdissant le module Orion s'est
détaché il filme maintenant vers la lune
pas d'astronaute à bord mais un
mannequin dans le siège du commandant
pour tester les vibrations et les
radiations reçues on veut vérifier que
le véhicule fonctionne on va le
soumettre aux conditions les plus
difficiles on va faire une mission
complexe et on va le ramener sur terre
retour prévu le 11 décembre après 25
jours de mission vous allez
magnifique voilà attention le chapitre
suivant de l'aventure ce sera en 2024
Artémis 2 emmènera cette fois des
astronautes de la NASA vers la lune mais
sans atterrir il faudra attendre au plus
tôt 2025 pour voir à nouveau des hommes
foulés le seul lunaire
53 ans après la dernière mission Apollo
en 1972 une femme et un homme de couleur
seront cette fois du voyage
de ce côté
patron
premier
faut que je me dépêche par contre me
mettre mon costume parce que là ça va
être une galère parce que là il me reste
quoi il me reste merci beaucoup la
grande librairie c'est tout de suite
après les actualités de Bertrand et
venez parce qu'on est formidable en
France on fait des faux duplex sur le
plateau de c'est à vous tiens bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
derrière
Trump avait promis cette grande annonce
lors de sa campagne pour les élections
de mi-mandat et il a donc officialisé sa
candidature en effet hier soir
écoutez-le
afin de rendre sa grandeur et sa gloire
à notre pays j'annonce ma candidature à
l'élection présidentielle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non non
[Applaudissements]
des éléments de langage qui ravissent
toujours autant ses fans une base
galvanisée qui écoutait le discours
derrière les grilles de la résidence
je suis si heureuse parce que je sens de
l'espoir il est ce qu'il nous faut pour
nous le peuple depuis 20 ans on n'a pas
eu de président élu dans ce pays ils ont
tous été choisis par la Kabbale et c'est
pour ça que Trump est devenu président
c'était une opération militaire pour
révéler toute la corruption
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Sarah qui a chanté sex bomb
[Musique]
sexy
et comment ça James
en espagnol
vous avez ce qu'on appelle une
importante communauté sur TikTok
Instagram et Youtube des vidéos
spontanées désinhibées et rigolote vous
êtes un champion de l'autodérision
comment vous pourriez expliquer votre
style on va vous images c'est le nouveau
roi de YouTube avec 112 millions
d'abonnés Mister Beast des trône
pewdiepie et devient le vidéaste le plus
suivi sur la plateforme ces derniers
mois cet Américain de 24 ans a fait
gagner une île déserte un de ses fans
passer deux jours dans une prison ou
participer au nettoyage d'une plage des
vidéos traduites dans plusieurs langues
pour toucher un public plus large on
sait qu'il reste encore trop d'ordures
une stratégie payante Jimmy Donaldson de
son vrai nom gagnerait 5 millions de
dollars par mois on va dire que je fais
de la merde sur les réseaux sociaux il y
a apparemment ça fait rire les gens
quel est le plus long fleuve de France
le
Ron je vais la gifler
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi c'est la scène